[music] we
continue to more without electricity,
water, heat, there are small nuances with
provision, namely, there are not enough analgesics now, in
general, we have been at the
workplace for more than a week, someone is even more,
so we
continue to work everything at our workplaces,
a big blow  I don’t know what the culture is
not to understand everything is so dark everything is
blurry trying to get up you can’t fall
crawling understand the leg despite it you don’t
understand whether it is still there or not I’m
crawling overturned I see many
there is Serezha put on the horizontal bar behind me
or even saying it’s
very scary